- Welcome back y'all.
Our next guest spent
decades singing, dancing,
and acting on stage and screen.
Now she is focusing on other
more personal pursuits,
like being a children's author.
Her second book is called
See You On The Other Side,
and it's all about helping kids
cope with change and grief.
Everybody, please
welcome back to the show,
Rachel Montez Minor.
(crowd cheers)
(theme music plays)
Nice to see you again, how are you?
- I am amazing.
New York looks good on you, girl.
- Thank you, I love it here so much.
I do.
It's like given me a whole new life.
I love it.
That's that's what I wanted, so
thank you God, universe for that.
- New York baby!
(crowd cheers)
- How is your hubby?
How's Ricky, how's your daughter?
- [Kelly] Ricky is amazing.
We just came off doing the Kennedy Center.
- I was like, he's been doing a round,
I've been seeing him everywhere playing-
- You know Ricky, whenever there's music.
And the Emmy's, he was nominated.
And yeah, just getting ready
for like the Clive Davis pre-Grammy.
- Oh my gosh.
- My daughter's five now
and it's the most amazing time.
This holiday season was like,
we were in perfect cuteness for Christmas.
It was like the perfect, it was five.
She was really believing it was amazing.
- Oh, I love that.
And then they open the,
it's just more magical
with kids too, I feel like.
It just, I don't know.
It ignites like that kid
in all of us, I feel like.
- Yes.
She told me "Santa came, but
Rudolph couldn't make it."
- Dang!
I was like, "He didn't make it?"
"No, but Santa came,"
(both laugh)
- She's like, "I was really bummed."
I love that.
Okay, so wait, the book
I think is very important
because talking about grief,
loss, death, anything like that
with kids, like, I remember my daughter
started, I think around like four.
Like really talking about
like what, where did they go?
What does this mean?
And then it starts to freak
them out the older they get.
I think this is such an important book.
- Thank you.
- So it's called See
You On The Other Side.
So how did this concept hit you?
- Well, it came to me in a dream.
- [Kelly] Like the first one!
- Yes.
Just like The Sun, The Moon and The Stars.
That came to me in a dream
and that was more about our
connection to the universe.
This one's about our
connection to each other
and how love never ends.
- Yeah.
I tell my daughter that I,
it's more my daughter that
gets freaked out about it.
Right now, I don't know if my
son is more aloof about it.
But it really, it terrifies them at first.
And I remember, remember
when you were a kid,
you found out and you
were like, wait, what?
Like what happens?
And it can be terrifying.
So it's so important not
just for kids, this book,
but also for parents to buy,
to start the conversation with their kids.
- Yes.
And it's really is a
tool to help for any time
of change, you know?
It teaches us that change is natural
and it really connects us to this power
that love just goes on and on
and it's everlasting.
- Did something happen within your family
or something, like was
there loss in your family
to where it kind of triggered that
for you to write something?
- Yes.
My grandmother and I
were very, very close.
She lived to be 96 and she
was a huge part of my...
- Great genetics there, I like that.
- She's probably 95 there.
Can you believe that skin?
I know.
But she used to take me to Muir Woods.
We would travel together
to national parks,
and my parents both worked full-time jobs,
so she was a big part of my childhood
and farmer's markets and dance class.
So, yeah, I mean, it
came to me in a dream,
but maybe like subconsciously,
because nature is such
a big part of the book
and teaching them that
change is a part of nature.
So I feel like, you know,
maybe that was her working
through me and in some of the
spreads, you know, in order
to connect with the people we love.
Like, I like to cook the
same recipes I made with her,
or we go on the same walks
or go to the same beach.
- It's kind of keeping
them alive in a sense.
- It is.
And there's lots of like real examples
in the spreads about how to connect
to those we love and keep
that connection going,
but in a very, like uplifting
and soothing and positive way
and what a gift to give our children.
That, you know, change is, it's natural
and it's positive and
we can stay connected
to all of those that we love.
- Yeah, I agree.
It's a constant conversation
I have with my kids.
(audience applauds)
So thank you for the book, everybody,
Rachel's new book is called
See You On The Other Side.
It's out now, get it
wherever you get your books.